my first two in-studio guests are
invited back for multiple big slicks
here in Kansas City I'm sorry I think
it's big slick now that is somebody who
sounds like he's just chock-full of
gravitas that's like like Attorneys
General
I just wanna Jake Tapper CNN Jake Tapper
Jake Tapper CNN it and will forte here
on the Rich Eisen show good to see you
gentlemen how are you good to see you
very good now is it true that when we're
done here in Kansas City you guys are
gonna go to Branson and open open up as
you know opening up together tapper and
Forte or is it we're right across the
highway from Yakov Smirnoff
yuk yuk chop what a country and it's
true and in Branson audience watches you
but now is we have a two-for-one deal
Waltzing waters yeah yeah okay so now it
makes sense have you been to Branson it
is good to see you guys here
now I want to describe for the radio
audience or would you care to Jake
Tapper what is on your feet what do you
have Eagles Super Bowl commemorative
sneakers with big Screaming Eagles I'm
not really sure what the texture of the
material is okay as I was explaining to
you before this is an indication that
the Facebook algorithm knows me too well
and knows what a sucker I am because
this this popped up as did this shirt
and the shirt is again sure it is the
Robert Duvall character from Apocalypse
Now Lieutenant Colonel Kilgore it's his
the surf shop t-shirt he was wearing so
now nonsense that is sold in my facebook
feed and I buy immediately
now do you wear - have you ever worn
this on the lead Jake Tapper would that
be underneath loafers the the coat of
armour I have a more subtle reference to
my team this is the silver of the silver
and black Oakland Raiders black jeans
okay and and by the way and I feel bad
saying that in you know but that's okay
nope the Chiefs are right over the the
side of the stadium right there and is
that cool with you and Stonestreet and
the rest of these Chiefs fans did you
know they accept that you have your team
and you're a die-hard
word of your teaming like I would not if
a Chiefs fan came to Oakland I got it's
still America rich yeah still the United
States of America it is that and we all
we all have our freak flag that we're
flying our colors you fired up about
Gruden will John are very excited about
gritty yeah very very excited I'm I'm
I'm still wrestling with the move to
Vegas that that's a tough very tough
thing for me did you grow up in the
black hole an Oakland in right outside
other when I was born in Oakland
California okay grew up about 15 minutes
away from there right and it was tough
when they even just went down to Los
Angeles and then I moved down to Los
Angeles but it still was never the same
when they weren't in Oakland and you
know those fans are great fans and they
sat through a lot of seasons with where
they were not doing well and then a
sudden they start doing well again
they're ripping them out of there and
going to Vegas I'm a little upset about
it but I'm trying to forgive have you
ever done the face paint situation you
ever done that I've not done the face
paint just like the paint everything but
it's a black hole and I somehow have
become friends with Phil Villa piano and
his family and they're fantastic and
wonderful and we'll go to games every
once a while together that's old and
that guy should be in the Hall of Fame
you're pounding the table for Philip
Villa piano right here on the Rich Eisen
show which is fine that's great but let
me ask you this question sir when it all
comes down to it would you in perhaps
the last year of the Raiders or to go do
the whole face paint like the violator
one of those type of characters just
show up and do it I love it well the
challenge to do that yes that would you
have to shave the beard I think all
right well how about this so if if will
does that Jake yeah you've got to go
climb one of the poles been grease it up
previously great yes that you which by
the way how do we go fans still climb
those when they
and breadcrumbs I'm prepared to make
this deal to do the base man if he clams
up the greased bowl Jim you mean that
euphemistically you just shook hands
yeah his career just got destroyed he's
got a big best-selling book in the
Hellfire Club he's leading with Jake
Tapper he stated the unioning by the way
is that is that the proper way to do it
or it's just you know I you can I just
verbalize I'm not a stickler you want to
turn in you want to turn it into a
gerund it's fine with me by the way
thank you for dropping the word journey
for the first time its history last
three and a half years ago right Chris
we've never had a gerund I didn't know
what that means so what does Jake Tapper
and and Will Forte here in all
seriousness that championship for the
Eagles yeah what what does that mean for
somebody like yourself people that you
know people have been waiting for it is
long I mean so I'm 49 so I've never
experienced the football championship in
my life and when the Eagles were first
in the Super Bowl in I mean I'm not in
my life because they were what were they
they want to they won the championship
in 1960 before it was a Super Bowl very
right but that was pre me pre so I was
11 when they played the Raiders in
January 81 in the Superdome yeah way
back there meal versus Plunkett and you
beat us and then I was 20-something and
I mean so it was just an unbelievable
feeling I was there as you know I went
to the game I went to the NFC
Championship game in Philly took my dad
I mean it was amazing I feel like it's a
it's a bucket list even though obviously
I did nothing except watch and you've
just checked it off that's good oh I
mean at least you at least you were you
were there always it's like me and Ilsa
in Paris no matter what happens so
that's a Casablanca reference right
there it is will you you showed up on a
95 degree day here in Kansas City in
flannel and a shirt you're layered with
flannel on either and the size throw
wolves all socks what are you doing Wow
well long underwear
now that's particularly on before I let
you go and head back before the
celebrity softball game and we've got
our two of our hosts here at the bigs
like why you guys keep coming back here
to this event the kids I mean it's you
we get to go and visit the hospital and
see all these kids that were raising the
money for and and the the between the
kids and the whole staff at Children's
Mercy is just an amazing amazing
organization you know so it makes it
very easy yeah going to see the kids on
the Friday morning a big slick is the
highlight of the trip I mean it's great
hanging out with will it's great hanging
out with the gang but but these kids are
so brave is very grand they're there for
their five they're six years old
their parents are there they're going
through stuff that we can't even imagine
and that's the most important thing and
it's also really touching to see Kansas
City just come together for this event
to raise money for this special Hospital
that takes care of kids regardless of
their means entirely just based on what
they need and 1.7 million last year
ready yeah I got a beat it now I do we
got to be that's that's right it's it's
it is a team effort we'll be there
tomorrow night at the at the final event
where where most of the money gets
raised but you can go to big slick
kc.org right now and donate as well as
be part of the live auction what
positions are you guys playing later on
today what do we have I'm kind of rover
I'm usually rover over yeah okay I'm
amazing you don't have the the replay
last year of when we got into a scuffle
on third base what like like Peter
Harrell's entire series it was pretty it
was a it was a pretty grim move I was he
was running and I was I was third base
and I it got a little physical hold on I
believe we have as they say in the TV
business b-roll look at you guys getting
down there it is okay years ago there's
the Broads high-fiving Travis Kelce but
these are just pretty boys showing pity
boys Vanderbeek okay yeah they're about
to have another baby
how about that yeah and he can't come
this year but just shows you right you
are just so happy to say Van Der Beek's
name and you said it with such derision
Jake well I'm just saying I wanted to
show you some nitty gritty yeah and you
just put up
I mean I love the guy but that wasn't
what I wanted the people to see he's a
Pacey
check out Jake every day when he's when
he's not here on Jake Tapper 360 I said
the the situation
no that was a great show the lead with
Jake Tapper 4:00 to 5:00 Eastern State
of the Union with Jake and noon Eastern
every single Sunday and then the
Hellfire Club congratulations thank you
and you will forte I cannot wait to hear
you sing later on tonight oh I can't
wait sing with you hopefully what you
what's your go-to uh James Ingram just
once or Merle Haggard can you give me
and you give everybody to to go to break
I guess to like Bill O'Reilly play us
out we're gonna do it live what do you
have that's a golfclap right there well
forte the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience